I respect that man you've been staying
quiet staying out the way recently
uh now you did do something that is some
old pump [ __ ] you destroyed a Porsche
was it a Porsche yes yeah
I have a history report just man like
well what was the for the video what was
your big music video where you [ __ ] up
a car let's get it so the Escape music
video yeah so this is this is a big
story and I never told nobody this one
so
I'm on the car right the this is not the
plan was not to break the car okay I'm
standing on it performing yeah I cracked
the window
and then I look down I'm like [ __ ] I
just broke the back of a wraith like
and that I just look at the [ __ ]
producer I'm like I'm gonna finish
breaking this [ __ ] like they're already
gonna charge me so might as well might
as well I grabbed the [ __ ] um golf
the golf thing yeah start breaking that
[ __ ]
and then after the video is done
I got a call like a week later like yo
um the owners don't want the car anymore
you got to buy it I'm like what like
this [ __ ] makes no sense right but I end
up buying a car and I got two of the
same whips and one's just [ __ ] up
one's just [ __ ] up and I fixed it
painted it how much did it cost to get
it fixed
they were trying to charge me like 40K
I'm like you're gonna charge me 40K just
let me buy the whole car wow yeah you
gotta buy the whip at that point yeah I
was like just give me the car damn bro
that shit's crazy